a spring valley family is beefing up
security tonight at their home after a
recent break-in and was all captured on
surveillance video two men broke into
their house while their son inside joe
muller live near desert jones and rather
jones and desert inn with their warning
brian denises could have ended up much
worse jeff liston says this is his worst
nightmare knowing someone broke into
their home all while their son was
inside
it's
very disturbing this shocking security
camera footage they ransacked my home is
now leaving jeff liston and his family
on edge a mask on kicked the door kicked
the door
another gentleman was with him i have
cameras here at my house that
he saw and knocked out of the way this
happened thursday at 5 30 in the evening
jepp and his wife were gone but their 14
year old son was in the house in the
room right next to the door
after this man knocked on the door his
son called him he was hysterical crying
um you know it was it was the father's
worst nightmare a minute later he
watched this all unfold i saw the
gentleman coming to kick the door down
and i told my son to run as quickly as
he can out the
garage through the side door to a
neighbor's home and he thankfully was
able to to escape to safety the home was
ransacked but nothing was taken liston
says they got away in this bmw sedan
we're going to get some
security gates
and some weapons days later his business
in downtown las vegas was also broken
into he says he worries about this
problem around the valley and wants
others to be alert we're not trying we
are going to protect our home as much as
we can so when the next time a guy like
this does this hopefully i can be
prepared
liston says the metro actually got to
their home in about seven minutes and
they are still actively investigating
this case and they are looking for
information so if you know anything
police would like to hear from you
reporting live in spring valley this
evening joe mulder live local now
coming